Appreciate it. Great thighs, good chest hair.
Nice face and a great stash.
We've got three shows in the park. This is the first one.
They're all in central park. We're going to do this one.
We're going to run to the other one on 79th and whatever.
Then we're going to do that one and come back and close these the third one out,
which is back here. This is comedy. Now it's in a park. There's no microphone.
You're basically just a hobo, screaming to strangers, uh,
in the park. All right, here we go. Culminate. All right.
Where do we begin? I mean,
we've got to address the elephant and the anal Corona. It's a, it's a. We all,
we're all sick of it. That's why we're here. You know, Corona has been so long.
It feels like the check engine light, you know, at first you're scared of it.
Then after a while, you're like, it. I gotta go to work. I hate it.
I can't believe this whole thing started because some guy the back.
Um, I feel like, uh, like a woman in arranged marriage. You know, I, uh,
I didn't choose this. I got to cover my face. And if I say my opinion,
I get yelled at all right.
I can't tell if I'm bombing or if in the park, we'll say both.
That was brutal. I mean, Hey, you're outdoors. You have no microphone.
There's no ceiling there's music. That was brutal. That was the first one.
My ego is through the floor. Let's go to the other one. Yeah, this is,
this is comedy now folks. It's a pretty depressing.
That's what we have to offer. Lot of skin. I think we're a little,
when my bill early to God starts in 10 minutes. We were perfect.
Hey, career, low point.
I don't know anything. I don't watch the news. Uh, I did hear R Kelly got, uh,
he got interviewed and he said a COVID 19 too old for me.
That's where you guys. All right, there you go. We're getting there.
It's crowds like anal. It takes a minute. Eventually. It'll feel good.
That's what my stepdad told me. Oh,
that's my stepdad. Whew. That is a miscarriage on wheels.
Holy hell God. That was,
that was appalling. Good luck. I don't even blame them. You know,
it's just not the right setting. Oh man. One more, one more.
Ah, well this is comedy companies are positive. Unlike Corona.
I hope on the next show. I get one laugh.
Ah, do we need to just for parking? This one is, uh,
hopefully one day I can open for Nick cannon. Let's go do that last show.
Hey, thank you.
I'm going to be a lot darker than the other guys. This is the great gig.
Next week. I'm doing a target Minneapolis. So I can't complain. Yeah.
Blackville got hit really hard by COVID,
which shocks me because they usually handle illness so well they're strong
people. I mean, look at magic Johnson. He's still going. All right.
Hell he beat Kobe.
That joke. I liked him. Didn't land.
Oh words.
This kills at a comedy club. Uh, but you guys are nice, you know, little square,
but you're all right. You know, some comedians out there. Hey, woke people.
I mean, none more than Cosby. Thanks a lot. I'm Kevin Hart.
Have a good night.
Last show of the night. We got three in and one park. That's gotta be a record.
Three shows in one park. I mean,
aside from a crazy hobo that's I think we set a new precedent
yelling at strangers, no microphone. Everything was against us.
I stepped on a heroin needle. I have AIDS, but comedy lives.
We've got to keep doing it. We got to keep going. You got to make it work.
I hate myself. I'll see you in hell Kanye 2020.